hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem video auf dass ich
gerade wer lange hingearbeitet habe ich
ihnen schon seit einer stunde einen wal
wow cool
wir befinden uns hier heute nämlich ingo
sie mir schon schwer erkennen könnt bin
ich hier einen wal und war jetzt fragt
ihr euch wie schön hey was hast du getan
hast du in walbeck habe eine website
gefunden auf der gesagt wurde dass in
der gold klettere merkt sehr sehr viele
collectibles gibt die man einsammeln
kann und wenn man die alle eingesammelt
hat dann wird man ein wal und dafür habe
ich gerade so lange gebraucht ich weiß
nicht was wir mit diesem warenkorb tut
er das wasser die aus dieser laser oder
so ich drücke die ganze zeit irgendwas
ich will ihn am liebsten irgendwie
bewegen aber ich kann mich nur seine
flosse bewegt sich eher leid der ebs der
leute erst mal ich bin dafür dass wir
gekriegt habe dass ich einmal binden
leute sicher wir schaffen doch e7400
verholfen
also lassen leider wenn solch
gefährlichen pocking waren hier mein
gott also ich mein freund nicht mit
diesem nicht gerade schaffen wenn paar
sekunden später möglich ich würde sagen
wir gehen bei einer anderen app mit dem
wahl
ich weiß nicht was sie da am besten
auswählen sollten als merke ich glaube
ich ihnen einfach macht ebay wollten die
berliner mieten anwender zumindest ein
bisschen wasser am start wäre übrigens
gold simi liter feiert und ihr wollt das
jetzt hochladen dann schreibt malta und
in die kommentare dann will ich das
wunderbar rollt sich runter und freunde
da vorne das wasser das heißt es könnte
jetzt sein dass der wahl sich im wasser
zumindest vernünftig bewegen kann
nein der wald hier nur um wels weg ins
lege mein gott okay leute wir haben
gegen die hingekriegt dass der wald sich
jetzt mittlerweile wie ein aal er bewegt
war unfähig ist los mit dem alter ich
dachte der ist irgendwie so richtig
schön
und der basler motion frau sieht der
richtig cool aus mit seinem unterkörper
ich dachte oh hallo probierte viel
mitnehmen was ist los mit diesem free
und warum wird der wieder irgendwem zu
läutet eine hand an der tastatur mit dem
wali auf jeden fall am ich los mit den
leuten singles mit der kabine
wahrscheinlich steht er gleich wieder
auf
das steht da und da liegt er wieder
jetzt läuft er natürlich auch nicht nur
auf den wald das ist nicht wahr als wenn
er nicht einfach so hallo ich bin ein
wahl
was beweist du die ganze zeit es ist
sowas von unmöglich mit diesem wal
irgend etwas anzustellen in diesem spiel
ich dachte dass weg von wegen down your
dario simulator vol klug armee
helikopter
das geht ab in dieser meditation macht
dir mal mit dem mythos ruhig vorher
schon mal zwei stunden damit wir die
ganzen teile krieg und den ball spielen
kannst aber lass mich dieser wahl und
ist wirklich was kann ich denn machen
mit diesem beschissenen wahlleute ich
habe nie den
ich habe nie die ich weiß was möglich
ist aber ich probiert mal ich habe jetzt
wieder den wal ausgewählt allerdings
jetzt schon jetzt vorne dafür ein
jetpack oben drauf an dass theoretisch
wenn wir drücken haben wir ein jetpack
und böse das hat mit kölner ein bisschen
bewegen weil ich etwas fall nicht ins
wasser geflossen
warum warum jetzt sind wir genau da wo
wir vor fünf minuten
ich mein wenn ich das jetpack anmache
dann hat mit mir noch eine kleine chance
vielleicht irgendwie schneller
vorankommen oder irgendwas anderes zu
machen
aber es wird hiermit sich das so
vorstellt ist das hier anderthalb bis
zwei stunden habe alle von den propheten
eingesammelt auf jeden fall habe ich
dann von allen eingesandten gedacht okay
ich habe eigentlich zwei wochen nochmal
eine also habe ich mir gedacht okay und
bin danach eine wahl von rosa
interessanter war und bin ich tot er
er dreht wenn hier jemand von euren
eltern oder brauchen freut euch fragt ja
das macht klug hat einen sorg youtube
womit macht er geld was warum macht
derzeit den einfachen dafür 2000 jahre
später heute wird ein automat voraus wir
liegen jetzt starrt mich allerdings eine
trophäe eingefangen habe bekomme ich
nicht nur den wahlen sondern kann auch
jetzt hier anstatt riesige auch eine
große ziele auswählen das große ziel
klick aufgefallen natürlich darf ein
name nicht nur riesengroße dazu kommen
sondern auch große ziegel und das ist
eine giraffe das warst du ja eigentlich
schon wieder ich dachte wertingen dahin
gelaufen
was macht eine frau was wird sie im
schilde frau ganz okay wir galoppieren
jetzt als die rache einfach mal sagen
sie liegt da so als wäre sie tot als
letzter ein anstrengender tag
ich verstehe einfach nicht wie eine
giraffe in die gespielt hat ich meine
das ist endlich eigentlich immer noch
der gold die me later nicht irgendwie
war oder giraffen im juli auf den markt
da sind zwei leute und die lauten
einfaches game ich kann euch 100 prozent
[Musik]
ich wollte wirklich leid der nächsten
sekunde sollen aber die ich konnte nicht
mal mein mann verändern und die sind
schon gefallen was geht ab mit diesen
menschen also ich meine das spiel mit
der beliebten k s mit abstand von allen
spielen motive later jäger fahrende
rutsche wo ich jetzt runter rutschen
kann in richtung wasser und berlin schon
wieder zwei leute aber es wird wirklich
ein ort an dem ich glaube ich noch nie
war meiner kompletten die
militärkarriere also hier vorne die
trophäe wurde haben wir die einst von 31
das ist ja ein richtig guter wert hier
zum start in der map ich war noch nie
hier vorne wird gegrillt wird hier
nicht mehr gegrillt leute ich habe einen
deal und weiß dass auch die
trockenlegung rat zu kommen weil die
haben keine tarife für giraffen und ich
passe auch nicht in so eine gondel
ryanair werde jetzt einfach mal so
machen werde hier die seite hoch laufen
und von dem riesenland wegspringen
genauer an eine laterne mitnehmen die
dann hinter mir und wasser knallt genau
das war meine intention ist muss doch
irgendwie möglich sein hier ob diese
verdammte riesenrad bekommen hier stehen
dann hier die wand hochlaufen und jetzt
einfach von der anderen seite genau wie
darunter fallen
wir schauen wir noch an fächern haben
neben der großen sich unter riesen sind
auch noch eine feder liege das einfach
mal aufspielen leute ich bin wirklich
sehr gespannt also die große siege war
bisher die rache obsiege war ein wal und
in ostritz
den strauß ich meine sieht jetzt schon
cool so dass ich irgendwie ein strauß
bin aber so die sache einfach echt kennt
halb voll
das finde ich nicht so cool so sprintet
der strauss kahn der fliegen kann
wirklich bisschen fliegen
ich habe mich jetzt einfach mal dorthin
gewählt wo ich wirklich meine freunde
auch wieder finde und war beim müll
damit würde ich nämlich auch meine
spielleistung heute gleich stellen ist
einfach ein longboard und jetzt kann ich
als ritt auf dem erst richtig motiviert
longboard uhr 2017 meine damen und
herren das geht ab so maser spart also
hier aus führt auf dem longboard model
hier das denn schlechter drauf
hochziehen
wo bin ich lego universe amparo mann war
nicht meine absicht ja leute die haben
sicherlich schon gemerkt ich habe im
heutigen video ein bisschen weniger
gestritten weniger ist natürlich auch
noch meine standards gemacht die hand
mit dem run so dass ich jetzt auch
gerade wahrscheinlich wieder mache aber
halten bis die weniger was musik und
tanz und so angeht liegt einfach daran
dass ist derzeit voll in der
klausurphase bin aber ich bin halt auch
kein mensch ändern sagt ja ich mache
zwei wochen keine video weil dann bin
ich mir selber unproduktiv vorkommen und
letztlich lieber mit unterdruck und
machen das wie demenz euch gefallen hat
wie gesagt lassen leichter 4000 leichter
wird zu beginn schon gesagt hat einen
job oder durch firma tausend menschen
krank auf jeden fall beendet jetzt an
dieser stelle das video wenn euch
gefallen wie gesagt vielleicht findet
jetzt hier oben einen zweig eingeblendet
wenn ihr da draufklicken in einen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren
da oben findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendet wo am ersten sechsten eine
neue sommerkollektion wert von hier
unten ist ein anderes video verlinkt
ja